let's jump to this next story from new
from the cut New York turfs are
boycotting Ulta beauty I'm not ready
last week Ulta beauty featured trans
influencer Dylan Mulvaney on its podcast
the beauty of during which she sat down
with gender fluid hairstylist David
Lopez to talk about her conservative
upbringing coming out as trans and
chronicling her journey on Tick Tock I
know I can find love and now I can still
be a performer I know that I can have a
family she said I want to be a mob one
day and I mom one day and I absolutely
can featuring a trans woman on a podcast
about girlhood was apparently too much
to bear for hordes of transphobic
Twitter users who are now calling for a
boycott of the beauty company let me
pause the hashtag boycott Ulta the the
women are saying it's two adult males
discussing quote the beauty of girlhood
let me just show for you the
introduction to the podcast which is
causing outrage and we're on day 167 of
girlhood Mr Hollywood who I'm right here
Hollywood zoom in on that well like what
what was Dylan doing with putting the
hands like that and then shaking like no
no talking about girlhood no no but what
is that move is that a thing that's like
that's like the shimmy shaking your
boobs like like Mr Hollywood look at the
camera type [ __ ] yeah oh yeah well so
this this story's uh been going viral I
think this this video came out last week
now they're saying boycott Estee Lauder
because Estee Lauder also featured a
trans person and uh I don't know Blair
we'll take it away there's just like a
lot to unpack okay so first of all the
idea that it's turfs who are upset over
the Ulta video seems pretty ridiculous I
mean I get called a tarfest by the fact
that I'm trans and not a feminist which
it's trans-oclusionary radical feminist
how am I both of those things uh it
doesn't make any sense
um so you know people are upset and
honestly it's because of Dylan Mulvaney
which first of all why didn't you change
your name why are you still Dylan um
second of all there's something really
creepy about like in adults claiming to
be experiencing girlhood like even if
this person is going to run with the
idea that they can become an actual
woman and even if that's the narrative
that doesn't make you a girl so it's
it's weird like infantilizing thing
that's disturbing so my look
I think this might be a troll I wish and
and you know I don't know how you you
talk about this while trying look
I don't care if someone's gender fluid I
don't care if someone's trans people can
live their lives if they want to hang
out in fact this is interesting you
brought up that you've been on the show
this your fourth time and we've never
actually talked about any of this stuff
not once in fact in the car up here I
was like it's really cool that they
don't have me just to only talk about
transfers but like I'm ready to finally
talk about something and people have
been begging me to talk about Dylan
mavini so really yeah it's one of those
things because a lot of trans people
hate it gay people hate it it's like
just the stuff that Dylan says you know
well let me play this video many of you
may have seen but this like you saw the
pushing the chest and shaking thing let
me let me let me play this video which
has been viral for some time now being a
girl and today I'm in nature
trees I love them
water lakes I love them
heels they're my hiking heels I love
them okay so we'll just we'll just go
step actually let me play this next part
I love them okay come on
so first I'll start with the hiking
heels this is why I say I feel like this
is a troll women don't do that this is
not girlhood there's there is nothing
about wearing high heels while hiking
women go hiking all the time they have
boots you go to the you go to the REI
and they have a women's section for
athletic boots what about being a girl
means you wear high heels in the
wilderness well this is a sexist's idea
of what and do right so it's that that's
the thing about wokeness is it always
comes full circle it's like we're gonna
erase stereotypes and people are more
than the sum of their stereotypes and
now it's back at the point where it's
like actually we are all just stereo
like this I understand why people think
this individual is making a mockery or
trolling them because like
we're not seeing people rag on you over
things like this I know people that know
Dylan and it's not a troll it's a real
person no I know Dylan's a real person
no I mean like it's not like they really
do identify as trans and this is their
like really disgusting childish view of
what that is are you sure because
there's another video released by uh
Dylan literally talking about how we
have to normalize women having bulges in
their pants as they wear tight pants hey
so that seems like a total job but also
also another big part of the boycott uh
boycott rage was that Dylan Mulvaney did
a video with a bunch of tampons like a
handful yeah like like a like a novelty
amount saying that you know they've been
carrying them around for a long time but
don't need them and then refers to
women's junk as Barbie pouches and but
like oh my God no no but like
what we're seeing let me play this again
I want you to listen to this I hiking
heels I love them okay come on
that laugh I'm gonna have an aneurysm
like look man
this is maybe maybe they're genuine and
that's just who they are and okay but
you know all of these things together
which are seemingly intended to be as
offensive as possible to women like the
end of this video is let me let me let
me jump to it where Dylan Falls bug
watch
oh
Falls over
[Music]
very fake gotta get out of here like
you're wearing heels in the woods is not
a thing women do
like like what's that outfit too is that
like a workout
a workout bra and underwear what is this
what is he wearing so I I suppose what I
guess I guess what I'm trying to say is
women aren't scared of bugs there is a
stereotype of women being scared of bugs
but there are many women who go hiking
they're they're I Googled famous female
uh entomologists there's like tons of
women who've made major discoveries and
with insects this just seems like Dylan
is trying to insult women uh by engaging
in the most extreme and offensive
stereotypes possible I'd liken it to
someone putting on blackface and then
screaming about Fried Chicken but I'm
not trying to be I'm not trying to be
mean I'm trying to call out someone I
think is intentionally trying to be
offensive like I'll say it again wearing
high heels in the woods is a joke like
that's not a real thing you know I don't
think Dylan's like trying to offend
people I think Dolan is just such a
narcissist that it's just like you know
this person went viral on Tick Tock they
had this huge following I think it's
just this is Dylan being a narcissist is
not care and what how it looks right so
it's the over top over the top like
caricaturized like oh a bug and falling
and acting stupid right it's like the
stupid woman stereotype so yeah it's
just such a narcissist he doesn't care
how it affects people I think that's at
the beginning of the ultimate video he
said this is day 150 of girlhood so he's
newly transitioned and how Dylan got
like famous was documenting day one day
two day three and these like really
stupid videos
um so yeah like who does this help right
it helps Dylan because it gets followers
and whatever but like yeah yeah it
pisses off women definitely pisses off
trans people it just hurts everyone and
the Ulta thing I think we were talking
about earlier how it's really it's like
the market has kind of capped with women
buying Cosmetics it's like now they have
to sell to males that's it right there
that's the answer right the reason why I
think they do the beauty of so look
capitalism is why you are going to see
more and more of this and there's
nothing you can do to stop it even with
the Ulta boycott it's very few women who
are going to do it the average woman
says I don't care about politics I just
need you know Foundation 122 or whatever
number it is I don't know we've got
we've got a bunch of makeup because for
people to show when they want to cover
stuff up so we have all the different I
don't even know anything about it but we
went to like we went to Dollar General I
just grabbed a thing I said there you go
now we got makeup we have a makeup
department but so the average woman
well Salton just says I need Foundation
they're not going in about did you see
the latest podcast with Dylan Mulvaney
what this does do however is for gender
non-binary people for Trans people they
are expanding their market share Ulta
and Estee Lauder and these other
companies are like we have maximized the
amount of money we can make what do we
do well we can release a new top of the
line eco-friendly version it's like
we've done that over and over again what
if we sell to men men don't wear makeup
what if we create a culture around males
actually wearing makeup surprise
surprise big YouTubers that are males
who wear makeup be they trans or gay or
just for like there are just straight
guys that are you know Metro or whatever
they call it who wear makeup this is a
this is a Maxima maximum market share
opportunity for Ulta they're probably
having meetings saying we don't care
about the culture we care about can we
sell more and now we can we have just
opened up half the population that we
were missing before yeah it's true and
there are like tutorials on YouTube for
like how to wear like straight man
makeup it's like they're really
expanding it you know but I'm gonna I'm
gonna invest in the in the beard
trimmers for women uh industry very soon
now right there's a pro athlete recently
who started a makeup line a male really
I think he's a Yankees player or someone
male makeup I mean male makeup has been
a huge thing in Korea and K-pop scene
for a long time yeah that's true that's
true yeah there you go yeah don't mess
with K-pop fans either we're talking
about anime fans it's hard you're
talking about that I was like dude don't
touch the padded underwear yeah women
got padded bras boys it's time they've
had underwear and chicken Cuts those
already exist chicken cutlets yeah you
don't know what chicken cutlets are no
no it's you know how much in your bra
Women fake dudes yeah chicken cutlets
yeah they have like literal they kind of
look like chicken
oh but like it's like it's like bras oh
no no no no no no you put it in the bra
oh right right the woman look like she's
more busty oh like in uh the misery
misery business music video you know
Paramore oh yeah and they rip it out she
pulls them out of the girls bra I'm
starting the woman's scape business this
is official I needed a company I needed
a product woman escaped for right now
we're doing this anyone in the mail
sculpting industry hit me up right now
and we'll do this you know what's
interesting about the Ulta thing though
is that they had the comments turned off
and then they turned them back on it was
a bunch of hidden replies but I think
they got dragged so hard for hiding them
now they're allowing them but I mean
it's Bleak it's like no one likes this
stuff and the blanket you know phrasing
that it's all turfs that are upset about
it it's like I don't think even 20 of
people who are complaining about it know
what a Turf is right yeah there's I've
seen a bunch of videos from just like
run-of-the-mill college age women being
like two adult males talking about
girlhood is offensive it's the weirdest
thing to me though in the hierarchy of
Oppression that like women are now
basically off like women throughout
history they you know they say
patriarchy all these things and all of a
sudden you've got biological males
talking about girlhood and when a woman
speaks up the woman is the problem well
this is the problem with the Trans
movement in general and why like I
learned very early on even despite being
trans that I didn't want any part of it
you know it's like it's not just about
you for these people it's about everyone
else as well so it's not just enough for
Dylan to be like this is me it's like
Dylan saying this is me and it doesn't
matter how far I take it everyone just
has to be cool with it you know like
there used to be this goal within the
trans community of like an integration
into society and it's the exact opposite
now now it's just adversarial
relationship and it's a movement that
poses a threat to women and children now
which I don't think any movement that
even is perceived that way yeah and
survive well I I think you know thinking
on a deeper level in my own personal
opinion the last few years there was a
psychological emotional and physical war
against men and I think that war was
very successful and it destroyed manhood
masculinity testosterone sperm levels
you name it the modern man has been
pretty much subjugated and destroyed now
I think the agenda is moving up towards
women and I think the same thing is
happening to women right now and we're
seeing the early phases of this larger
psychological mental physical and and uh
emotional attack that they're going
through do you think one solution Luke
might be that men should sunbae their
testicles uh well you got to be careful
giving too much heat on your balls
because it's actually bad this is a
Tucker Carlson reference does it work
yeah I actually did a video about this
on my own whole members area should you
suntan should you red light your balls
uh short and sweet of it I'm not gonna
make you go there and watch it just to
get the answer no because it's too much
heat and too much heat on on your balls
it's not good for you this is why a lot
of people say you know holding a laptop
in your lap is actually really bad for
you especially when it comes to your
reproductive organs keeping your balls
cool is actually what you should be
doing and what a lot a lot of fertility
doctors are selling them to do so you're
saying skinny jeans is a conspiracy by
Bill Gates to reduce the population
could be I don't know if it's by Bill
Gates it's probably by the fashion
industry which is connected to a lot of
people who love to go on that island
that we love to talk about Mr Epstein's
Island so so the fashion industry again
a lot of the top people Victoria's
Secret you name it all those fashion
Moguls there's a reason I think
personally they try to make their models
look like little young boys
um I I think there's a there's a reason
for this specifically there's a big
connection to a lot of very Sinister
really bad people but but yeah men have
been essentially de-masculated you know
just just kicked out just just destroyed
I think now we're seeing the beginnings
of the destruction against uh women and
you know I wore skinny jeans as a kid
and now look at me so wow
just saying I don't I don't see any of
this going away because no there's more
money to be made than lost it's just
that simple
yeah like think about anything any kind
of product that has it has a small
market share and you will see them try
to expand it this is what we've been
seeing across the board the reason why
you know Disney is trying to do uh
diversity is it's not because many of
the younger employees are probably fully
into the die cult but a lot of the
executives are just like we're not
making enough money like we've
capitalized the white Suburban mom
Market how do we get these other markets
and it's like well you've got to make
products for those markets so this is
why there's a conspiracy theory that
there's a mixed race agenda because all
commercial like almost every commercial
now she's a mixed race family yeah it is
not because they're trying to get people
to mix to race mix it's because they're
trying to make one commercial with one
budget that will be like that will cater
to a black person and a white person at
the same time the problem is it ends up
just being alienating for everybody
because people don't relate to these
these like you do a commercial where
it's a family in a suburb regardless of
race with granite granite countertops
and they're pouring bowls of cereal or
making Rice Krispies Treats together
that is meaningless to people who live
in cities that is not a relatable
experience doesn't matter what your race
is but a lot of people are conspiracy
this will see that and they'll be like
they're trying to convince us to to have
interracial relationships and it's like
bro I think that might have been like 60
something years ago right now they're
just trying to not spend money on
marketing that's that's the that's the
real conspiracy and what better way to
Market than to stir up controversy than
to have everyone talk about it oh
absolutely it's true like elta's
probably high-fiving their marketing
team right now for this right like we
nailed everyone and they're going
through a lesson they're going to be
like we got this podcast is but Tim cast
IRL talked about it for 20 minutes and
they're gonna go wow good job guys and
there's something to that because it's
like as much as the video annoyed me and
it's gross and you know I maybe won't
shop there for a couple weeks it's like
when this is the back of my mind just
gone in history I'll just be shopping
all day like yeah you're gonna be like
walking down the street looking at your
phone as someone criticizes this and
then you're gonna look to your left at
Ulta and they're gonna have new shiny
cosmetics and go and then you're gonna
turn your phone on walk inside and buy
it exactly but I don't mean that like
even for you I mean like most people
it's like look at all the things Netflix
has done and I'm willing to bet tons of
people who watch would still have
Netflix so uh you had cuties cuties you
also had uh you still have big mouth
which I can't believe exists as a TV
show yeah it's about uh preview besant
or I guess pubescent children having you
know adult interactions it's like their
puberty monster right it's like they're
they're yeah it's it's it's it's
children going through puberty and them
showing it right right like naked little
girls like you know little boys what's
the purpose yeah it's it's funny to them
I guess I I don't know is it like a
reality like it's a cartoonist cartoon
it's a cartoon it's a cartoon where the
characters are voiced by adults it's on
like season seven or something and
they've been subject to repeated
controversies one where it had like 12
year old girls cartoons mind you but
naked walking around in a bath house
with a bunch of other naked women
singing about why their bodies are
beautiful and the left was like it's
body positivity it's fine and people
were like why are they making a show
about sexualized children then they came
out with cuties it's not the first time
they've done this but despite all of
this I'm willing to bet a ton of people
who listen to the show and agree that
it's bad still have Netflix accounts I
personally don't I tell other people not
to have it other people I know who work
here they've got them and so it's like
what are you gonna do here's what I even
say become a member at timcast.com smash
the like button all that stuff however I
know that's not completely reasonable to
tell everybody to just cancel their
entertainment despite the fact that Hulu
Netflix Amazon evolving these bad things
people want the shows that are good or
the shows that are bad but in the end
the money that that you pay ends up
going to the bad stuff so what we're
trying to do is we're trying to make
culture and make content and it's just
not easy we're competing with
multi-billion dollar corporations and we
are a company of like 30 people but I'm
hoping that with the daily wire is doing
with what we're doing and of course many
others eventually people will just be
like I don't want Netflix for political
reasons but I also don't need Netflix
because these other platforms are
creating something that's entertaining
enough for me right I'm surprised of a
show on Netflix actually promoting
people going through puberty at all
because usually they're trying to like
block them let's be ready now well yeah
you try to create new customers with
getting men to buy makeup I mean when
you're convincing kids to become trans
you're talking about millions of dollars
per patient well yeah the money is also
in that too and there's a conversation
we had about big Pharma and yeah you
know trans surgeries it's going to
become like a billion dollar industry
now and like what better way than to
include kids you know when historically
that's just not the case it was always
like one or two one-offs in Sweden or
one of these more Progressive year
European countries and now it's like
kids in Texas the end result of so much
of this whether intentional or not is
population reduction thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there